arnacord voilà Thierry franchement vous
pensez qu'on l'a pas reconnu Cyril
Hanouna
voici mon stagiaire Tom villa
ça te va ça comme musique c'est super le
revision je vais vous appeler léonzi
trône et puis comme ça ça ira Thierry je
vous avouer que ce soit que vous me
surprenez voilà un journaliste un
rugbyman les Chevaliers du Fiel la femme
à barbe c'est le plus grand cabaret du
monde
mais c'est vrai vous avez bien fait
d'ailleurs de décaler Mimie Mathy parce
que sur la tête fait beaucoup d'un coup
c'est vrai que
les Chevaliers du Fiel les chevaliers
c'est très impressionnant parce que il y
a encore 10 ans tout le monde se foutait
d'eux et aujourd'hui il remplissent des
Zéniths ils font des prime sur des 8 à 2
millions de téléspectateurs c'est génial
ça fait 25 ans qu'ils font marrer les
Français comme les Balkany sauf que eux
ils le font exprès mais non mais nous on
déclare ce qu'on gagne
[Applaudissements]
non mais c'est vrai que on se méfie pas
parce que ils ont des têtes à bosser à
la DDE alors que c'est quand même les
fonctionnaires qui bossent le plus en
France c'est vrai alors votre dernier
spectacle s'appelle
Otake voilà je montre au taquet au
taquet comme ça voilà non c'est toujours
un coup d'avance parce qu'ils avaient
déjà anticipé la réforme de
l'orthographe bravo les gars
sans l'action circonflexe Xavier
Demoulin c'est vrai Xavier alors Xavier
vous avez failli être dans le Bronx
voilà vous êtes resté trois mois chez
les franciscains du Bronx voilà alors
qu'est-ce qu'un prêtre Francis quin dans
le Bronx le matin il prie et
l'après-midi il dit le la drogue voilà
c'est un cliché il y a des fois où il
prie pas euh
voilà Thierry franchement vous pensez
qu'on l'a pas reconnu Cyril Hanouna
je vous rassure vous inquiétez pas on
peut faire des blagues harnan voilà vu
qu'elle est anglaise j'ai donné un
mauvais texte à la traductrice donc tout
se passe bien
alors arnane Corse vous êtes la femme à
barbe voilà vous savez qu'en France ça
nous impressionne pas du tout parce que
nous on a déjà la femme à couilles c'est
Marine Le Pen donc franchement c'est
[Applaudissements]
bon
où est-ce qu'il me dérange c'est pas
qu'il y a une barbe c'est son pote là
avec les nichons dans les loges là par
contre je trouve ça
[Rires]
Philippe Saint-André alors l'ancienne
entraîneur du 15 de France de rugby
votre surnom c'est le goret PSA ou
encore ou un ou un
[Rires]
je vais rester sur Philippe Saint-André
parce que vous êtes trop près de moi on
sait jamais ça peut partir alors Thierry
je vous ai préparé un petit lexique du
rugby parce que je sais que c'est pas
votre domaine de prédilection non plus
lui oui mais non non non
pas du tout mais en même temps c'est lui
qui me paye c'était très drôle Thierry
mais alors voilà des petits termes
techniques du rugby par exemple le
tampon alors tampon plaquage très
violent alors point commun du tampon
entre les femmes et l'importation du
rugby lié au moment où les Anglais ont
débarqué
mêlée alors 8 hommes qui s'emboîtent
afin de conquérir le ballon voilà alors
ça c'est sur une pelouse parce que dans
le Marais ça s'appelle un bar bien
entendu
[Applaudissements]
mesdames et messieurs je suis ici pour
vous poser les questions trop con que
Thierry Ardisson n'a pas voulu vous
poser
Xavier de moulin alors Xavier de moulin
votre surnom c'est le sanglier on est
d'accord que vous n'avez pas la même
alimentation que le sanglier ça dépend
des jours ça dépend des jours très très
faim je suis capable de manger de tout
on mange des glands ça m'arrive
Harden Korn comment ça se passe dans les
hammam faut que vous attendiez les jours
mixtes du coup ou pas
tout la troisième mi-temps du match
après les All Blacks chez le psy
à Cardiff les chevaliers alors la
question que tout le monde se pose enfin
surtout Thierry qui dans votre duo écrit
les sketchs et qui fait la femme
et il fait la femme aussi il y a les
pièces
tu as eu juillet bonne émission merci
c'était Tom villa et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de innarditube abonnez-vous
et mettez un pouce bleu